i want to let you know i'm upstairs
with the return of the rat tour and i'll
be coming to your city
october 11th and 12th
wichita kansas we added the 11th at the
orpheum theater
so get those tickets october 13th omaha
nebraska and october 14th denver
colorado the first show is sold out
we've added a second
we may even add another one let's see
how it goes go to theovonne.com
t-o-u-r
to get tickets and make sure you go
through that link so you get accurately
priced tickets and don't get hit with
that upsell
thank you guys so much for your support
i look forward to seeing you soon i want
to let you know we have new be good to
yourself teas in new summertime
colorways like banana
salmon and other colors check those out
and more at theovonstore.com
thank you so much for your support
today's guest is a
uh a man that just
i mean just makes me feel so much dang
joy
when he's around he just makes me sprout
this damn
just happy tits just
just lunge out of my chest when he's
around
he just brings that out of you
he's a special guy he's originally from
another continent
and um he's always welcome here
this is his fifth time on this past
weekend
you may know him from mad tv from his
countless film and television
appearances or from his astounding
podcasts
tiger belly and bad friends
i'm grateful to spend time with him and
i'm grateful for him as a human today's
guest is mr bobby
[Music]
i'll lee and tell you my stories
[Music]
[Applause]
well you know when i when i've dated
white girls before every time i date a
white girl it just feels a little extra
special
really yeah like i won in some way oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
do you um why do you date a lot of
whites or not i haven't had luck i
haven't made love to a white in years
dog wow yeah
the first girl you ever made love to was
she fat no yeah yeah she was fat at
first
damn yeah yeah she was fat first dude i
got food poison one time hooking up with
a big girl
yeah vanilla no i think she just had so
much food in her and it it poisoned me
somehow
oh you ate that you ate the pop no no
she hit the box dude no i didn't did you
eat the box bro there was no she wasn't
leaving leftovers you know what i'm
saying it was yeah yeah everything had
been had been kind of uh
she was she there was she kept it all in
you know yeah but i mean i've always
wanted to make love to a plus-size model
oh i could see one there yeah like
they're beautiful but there's more
oh yeah i think there's more beauty
oh yeah there's as much well there's a
lot of like you see those plus size
models with the um
like a lot of them on the beach and
stuff now i like it yeah yeah think
about all the decades when bigger women
just had to stay inside and didn't want
to go outside
what do you mean
it just breaks my heart if you just like
now they can is what you're saying well
now it's more popular bigger women being
out and about and being in bathing suits
you know well back in the day if you see
like paintings at museums and [ __ ] right
there they used back in the day they
used that that was the sign of like
beauty oh yeah yeah i mean diabetes or
whatever reuben-esque yeah they were
yeah they liked it back then yeah the
lady would be laying by a stream with
like an apple or something or a little
ham what's all these grapes right yeah
all that sugar
yeah
yeah
all that sugar dude yeah yeah dude i
remember we used to go to the library
when i was young and
we'd look at those art you know i'd look
at the art of the drawing
a library not a museum oh no not a
museum i i feel like you've never been
to a museum
you've never been one you've never paid
tickets to go to museum oh well i did go
see body world that thing where they cut
people in half you know and they have
their bodies in there that's not a
[ __ ] museum
it's like a thing it seems like yeah
yeah it's like a one man you know those
people are chinese all the people that
they that are in there uh what
yeah well who's chinese the p you know
those people in the body world exhibits
where they cut the bodies you can see
inside the bodies and it's all like yeah
i don't know what that is you bring that
up
um
let me show you these people man looks
like a snuff film or no no it's a it's a
it's like an activity i guess
so this is body world you go you look at
the bottom right
you go so that dude what you're telling
me right now is that dude's chinese yeah
he just doesn't have any skin bro
[Laughter]
just because they don't have no skin
doesn't make it look
do chinese people look like they have no
skin look at this guy because it's
yellow i'm not saying that man oh you
were leading to that
yeah but that is
i think that but these people they buy
them out of china apparently because
these are real bodies they just take
some of the skin off
oh that's a real human being that's not
like a clay thing no that's real oh [ __ ]
dude that's body world you can go see it
and some of them are like
on horseback there's all kind of stuff
they're doing jab look at that one right
there with a javelin look at that guy
he's telling me that guy that's chinese
yeah for sure
and that dude is chinese bro
look how chinese he's so [ __ ] chinese
right now dude
damn and they sold him they sold his
body to this ex i mean it's just kind of
crazy you know
yeah um like there were still slaves
not that i'm a proponent of that or i
support it
but what like if you could get a slave
where would you get it from
that's a good question right oh yeah
yeah i mean i've thought about this a
lot
um my first instinct is mexico
really yeah
i just feel like they work hard
yeah they could be out in the sun you
know what i mean they can't do they do
the shingles and then the bushes
that's true right they just do all kinds
of stuff you know they know how to do
everything bro
they can't be out in the sun okay they
have to be out there to survive yeah
yeah but they're also the latest
immigrants really is mexican is mexicans
are the latest like leg of immigrants in
american history so immigrants are
always the ones that are out there doing
whatever right you know yeah yeah like
you guys had your time who's the you
guys
uh
asians asian people in general yeah was
when was our time you guys were those
real babies though
weren't y'all
yeah but the irish did it too bro oh
yeah yeah damn wonder was there beef
between the asians and the irish i
wonder no they got along i think wow you
have to be out in the sun like that yeah
do you think they drink lemonade oh dude
i always think if they drink a lemonade
and then they after they're done with
their ships the chinese give them opium
they party
dude don't you want to be
you and i dude back in the 1700s
oh we worked hard on the rails
because when asians do it we make that
sound that's how they got the name you
know that
is that how they yeah that's yeah that
crazy yeah that's how they do it yeah
with the real team
um but um and then after our shift we'd
probably like go to the [ __ ] den
and smoke opium together
and our souls that's when you're so when
you're high on opium and somebody else
is that's when your souls come out and
mingle
you think so yeah oh yeah man and we
would just look at each other huh or
would you close your eyes you think i'd
close them a little
to make it look like mine
[Laughter]
i didn't say that but i mean you know i
just want you to feel at home yeah but
back to the um
back to the the fa when the women were
fat back in the day oh i used to go to
the library i would get the book
and i would like um
it was whenever i like was first having
those times where you would like press
your wiener against something it would
feel so good you know what do you mean
like when you first started getting like
a lot of feeling in your wiener like
just like when your wiener just felt
like it just um
[Music]
just just had so much tendency in it
and uh
and i would press i would get a book and
i would it would be like those drawings
of the pictures of the women like rodin
or whatever the man's name was the
artist and now
i know
he was the artist he was drew those
women oh i thought it was like the
[ __ ] a reuben no godzilla's buddy
rodan oh rodan yeah yeah yeah whatever
that guy's name is lonnie rodan or
something who is it you bring him
and i would just put in rodan see what
comes up just rodan
that's what comes up with the rodan
oh no lonnie runner just put rodan in oh
lonnie rodan's a brother huh
this is a white guy
just put rodan in
that's that
that's rodan dude
oh that is it
is that the guy no yeah
r-o-d-i-n bub oh
there we go
that fool look at those thick i mean
that's when [ __ ] had whiskers
so would you jerk off to the the book i
would close the book on my on my wiener
until i like
reached orgasm i would like in in the
library yeah
wow can i say something i did dude this
is gonna i don't know if i get in
trouble for this but
um
so when i was in high school i used to
like do math
my freshman year yeah wow and what i
would do i get really horny
yeah now go to the library
and um there was these medical books oh
yeah yeah i mean like skeletons and
stuff you know or but sometimes they
would have a titty or whatever oh yeah
yeah yeah like a medical titty
yeah yeah and i would sit there and
would ditch class and i would sit there
and i would move some of the books to
the side to see if because it was like a
dead end
my aisle was at the dead and where the
medical books were and i was leaning
against the wall and i was scooted to
see there was no cameras back then right
yeah and i would jerk off to these
medical books oh cause i couldn't afford
porn back then oh i didn't know where to
even get it like i didn't have a car you
know how when you're freshman you don't
know how to get it oh you have to drive
that's back when you had to drive to
porn people like children now don't
understand don't forget how hard it was
to see even
a drawing or a sketch or even somebody
who'd make a little [ __ ] in the mud you
know or like a
mold of you know what i'm saying like
dude back then it was freaking
if you if you saw any hole it would feel
it would go you get hard oh dude i
remember i remember seeing like they
used to have these crawfish holes pull
that up crawfish uh
houses
crawfish houses there you go google in
on them zoom in on one of those mud
little
things
right there dude so these are things
that crawfish live in right that looks
like a dick
well find a shorter one go scroll down a
little
[Laughter]
no uh yeah right there one no no right
there on the left up oh i see now right
there no no
oh no oh [ __ ] that's a
that's a dick dude that one's uh another
deck that time of the month no go back
to right there that's a good so they
have something like this would be
everywhere these are all over louisiana
and this is where crawfish live in by
the ditches they get little houses yeah
and somebody wrote in good [ __ ] next to
it
in the dirt yeah yeah yeah
but dude it was i mean there was nothing
more exciting it was like it was such an
adventure once you were looking for i
used to buy cycle probably four to five
miles to get to my buddy's house his
family's house yeah and his dad would
keep porno under the sink oh yeah yeah
and i would go in there and tell him i
was doing a number two for like an hour
and a half really really yeah
it would take you that long to jerk no
but i would have to i would just be
there was like 11 books it would take so
long to get through all the information
yeah my friend alan meadows right his
dad was like collected porn but he would
hide it right but the fun was in the
hunt like the beatster bunny right right
and then like one time we found like a
magazine behind the cereals
oh i mean like it was like you mean
i found it i found it right and then we
would take turns going to the bathroom
and jerk off it would only take like
five minutes because it was like you
know we're kids
oh those are such good times now you
click on the [ __ ] computer
you see donkey [ __ ] and stuff oh man
yeah i've never seen that thank god but
um because there's other things you can
click on you know
there's nothing that's true that's true
right there's many options outside of
animalia
but the crazy thing was it used to feel
like if you had the porno
then you it was your thing now when
you're sitting with with pornography
video with porno video
it seems like there's 7 000 other dudes
watching the same time that's the part
that seems kind of gay to me if i'm if
i'm looking at porno video that's why i
look at the views
really yeah if it's one view i'm okay
with it oh yeah yeah i mean but it's
like four or five hundred views i feel a
little weird i mean like i'm sharing oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's it see that
would make porn real if they made you
see all the people that were watching it
at the same time oh like a zoom meeting
yeah you know what i do now is um i'll
go through porn and i'll go like you
know
they'll be like 50 boxes right oh yeah
but then they have ratings
and usually like i go to the site called
team skeet
you know what i mean and they have like
95 that's a pretty good number and i'll
go through and i'll jerk off to the one
that has the lowest number because i
feel bad really yeah like i'll go why is
this girl 60
oh she looks fine in the little
thumbnail and i'll press it and i'll go
yeah i know why now why does she have
asthma or something
or like what is there a certain why
would somebody have six why would asthma
be a thing i wouldn't
i feel like it would be hard for me to
ejaculate if somebody's having an asthma
attack so that's true that's true that's
true yeah i can't ejaculate if
somebody's having trouble breathing no i
think the numbers are based or the
rating is based on if the how the girl
performs
and usually if the rating if they're hot
and the rating is low
it means that they're like there's one
girl that was just literally not there
oh she's just going she was like doing
this like
oh man oh and just nothing on her face
yeah man wow like on drugs you think or
just like she had like she's just not
like she does like nearsighted
what or like what do you mean like on
drugs you're like no no no drugs no it's
just it's probably like
either it's like she doesn't want to be
there she's doing it for the money
it's really sad
yeah maybe near-sighted
yeah i wonder how much
we'll be talking about i don't know you
and you brought it up but i don't know i
remember i remember donkey [ __ ] i
regret saying that oh yeah and you
should yeah yeah i've never been around
anything like that i i we had a buddy
that used to he would you know come and
knock on the door if animals were
[ __ ] you know we had some animals not
far from us and if there was animal sex
going on he'd come knock on the door
and would you go check it out this guy
frankie uh i went the first time and
after that i knew something's wrong with
him you know
yeah yeah he would always try to he had
like a boomerang somebody got him like a
boomerang from another country for like
christmas or something one year and
australia do you think
i don't know i don't remember i don't
remember australia man but he would
always try to hit the animals that were
you know he had like a oh
he was just out there that was that's
weird i didn't like that kind of stuff
man we had people around us that would
always kill chickens and do stuff like
that do i do anyone that like
tortures an animal or hurts an animal i
just i cannot
i'll hang out with them yeah but i can't
get real intimate yeah yeah man oh yeah
i'll go bowling yeah
i'll go bowling or like you mean
i would do like uh you know batman yeah
you know i mean like a casual day on a
sunday right if they know they torture
animals but you ain't we're not gonna
have dinner
you know what i mean yeah we're not
gonna do it yeah three course of meal
yeah i'll do a spot with them or i'll
tour maybe would you tour with that guy
i mean you're kind of doing a lot of
them
yeah yeah i know but you i wouldn't hang
out after the tour
he's like hey you want to go look for
girls and i'll be i'm going to do my own
thing yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm not going
to be in a photo with them
yeah no photo yeah yeah would you like
if you were like um
let's suppose like you offered a movie
co-lead with a guy that you just know
was an animal abuser would you do the
movie
like that guy armor uh who's that guy
arnold hammer armor him he was people
not animals abusing people
what's worse people are animals
i mean i've met a lot of people i say
probably
animals that's worse to me because they
have no like people have choices
like don't burn me yeah i mean but the
you know a dog can't go
yeah
is that what a dog
yeah that's better right yeah yeah yeah
that's an owl
right that's a
racism crazy dude dude
if i walk by an owl and he did that i'd
probably get mad bro you would die
can we say that i can say it
i'd be like oh that's
dude do that that's because that's not
what he does right he had to force that
[ __ ]
i mean what the [ __ ] racist owl bro yeah
yeah yeah
oh damn dude i wonder if animals do get
racist do you think
oh
probably man yeah i like pit bulls don't
like me really yeah
wonder why
i think because they like black people
oh yeah is that a bad thing to say no
pitbulls love black people they love
black people yeah they love women and
kids
but asians i don't think they like
asians man wow yeah
every pit bull just growls up
like that damn yeah and has it always
been like
the whole animal kingdom i think if
noah's ark went by your house it would
just be a bunch of glue
[Music]
imagine if i was noah right i was on my
arc and they were all doing that oh yeah
they were yeah every time you turn your
back
they think you don't know which one it
is but they're animals so it's easy to
tell even the elephants are going like
with their little
doing this
like he brings his trunk up in
just one eye
that would be so funny you know what if
i was i'd probably just leave the boat
i would just be i can't handle this all
the [ __ ] animals are being racist
here i mean that'd be [ __ ] terrible
you know i mean i mean it would be
something maybe something dude yeah
you know it's silly to do things the
hard way
and i've learned that over the years man
doing things the hard way
i try to do a dang build a water
fountain in my yard
and i didn't have any water or anything
like that
silly to try to open a package with your
hand when there's a box cutter two feet
away it is
sometimes you can get by doing things
the hard way without realizing it but
when you run a business
doing things the hard way means you're
holding yourself and your business back
well shipstation gives e-commerce
sellers
an easier way to manage shipping it's
important so you can take all the energy
that goes into managing orders choosing
carriers and printing labels and use it
to grow your business no wonder
shipstation is already trusted by over
one hundred thousand sellers
it works with all storefronts at c e bay
amazon and more
it lets you automate processes like
fulfillment and tracking
so if you have a business you want to
use your time wisely let shipstation
do the hassling
actions like shipping sign up with our
promo code theo for a free 60-day trial
today at shipstation.com
and start breathing easier with every
shipment that's two whole months of
stress-free shipping and it's free to
try just go to shipstation.com click on
the microphone at the top of the page
and type in t-h-e-o ship station make
ship happen does it make sense to you
that the company who controls half of
online retail
also passively eavesdrops on your
private conversations at home
what about the idea that a single
company controls ninety percent of
internet searches runs your email
service and gets to track everything you
do on your smartphone
big tech is more powerful than most
countries are and they profit by
exploiting your personal data
that's why i use express vpn
with this with expressvpn on your device
the software hides your i p address
something big tech can use to personally
identify you
so express vpn makes your activity
harder to trace and sell to advertisers
and expressvpn does all of this without
slowing your connection that's why it's
the number one vpn service by mashable
and tech raider so stop handing over
your personal data the big tech monopoly
that minds your activity and sells your
information
protect yourself with the vpni trust to
keep me safe online
visit expressvpn.com
theo that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s vpn.com
theo to get
three extra months free go to
expressvpn.com theo right now to learn
more
i've been having this dream um
i've been having this dream where i keep
spending time with dennis rodman which
is crazy oh that's crazy north korea or
i don't know where he is i can't really
tell it looks like huntington beach
but um yeah that's been kind of crazy to
me
because we're doing a movie today can we
talk about that or no no we did talk
about um
that you and i wanted to do a tour in
north korea or what oh i think if we
toured north korea well how do we get
uh shin lim or
that's a magician it is yeah yeah shin
lim what's the guy's name young jock no
no no no give me the dictator's name in
north korea no just look at me don't
google it go okay you know what dude
little john
no i know what it is young john his
could i give you the first name yeah kim
oh kim yong john
kim yong john kim jong-un yeah
kim jong-un
i know it has a yawn in it because every
time i hear it i get tired
kim jong-yan yeah yeah what is it kim
jong-un kim jong-un yeah yeah yeah yeah
we're on set you're like how do we get
this is a weird thing because we're
trying to like do scenes and theo
[ __ ] ask bizarre questions like how
do we go to north korea and get kim
jong-un to like us yeah yeah and i'm
like dude can we do the scene bro but we
shouldn't do this thing because we need
to go to kim jong-un i know dude bro
what imagine if we rolled up there but
how do we get him here i'll make a plea
right now
mr oon arun
mr run
um
my name is theo this is my friend
bobby
and we want to say that we are proud of
you
ease up all right yeah yeah you're an
american bro sorry we want to say that
we know a lot we know about you
and
you've got a lot of fans here
you have great hair love the hair a lot
it reminds me of like a strong haircut
yeah yeah and talk about militario
um oh and you got beautiful uh like a
like you had cheeks for days dawg yeah
man you got cheeks for days you got them
little uh yeah you got them [ __ ]
frisky jowls boy yeah yeah you know just
like a damn little damn panda that's
just had a couple sugar pieces yeah you
probably have a cute penis oh
no well i don't want to end up seeing it
if we go but i'll take a peek yeah yeah
we'll take a p probably looks like a
minion yeah right right
here
yes that'd be cool dude right if you
pulled it out and it [ __ ] did that
with the little goggles bro he would put
we get him goggles and little [ __ ]
like overalls and put on his dick yeah
we want you to have a minion party and
we want to come to it
we would like to be ambassadors from
north korea to america and what we would
do is what what would we bring we would
bring um
some of your dvd we'll bring a lot of
cool magazines and stuff that you guys
don't have dvds
ebony i bet you they don't have ebony
dude or jet yeah yeah dude we got ebony
jet they don't get it there we'll bring
pictures of black friends that we have
yeah yeah like who uh
[Music]
donna rollins yeah donna rowling ian
edwards ian edwards yeah and even uh
we'll bring
we'll bring whatever you want but you
invite us and we're your guys yeah and
we'll will we work huh would we work i
think we're only going to stay for like
a week i think what would that be like
though i think it'd be sucky dude you
think yeah because it's like
first of all the food imagine the food
it can't be good he's an emperor
yeah he's not gonna be like oh come eat
my food yeah he will no he won't he's
not gonna come into my bed and eat my
food he's not going to do that you think
he's going to make us go somewhere else
no he'll probably go you stay hotel
we send you know food
right and then we're going to eat like
hat meat what the [ __ ] do they have
they're wrong now you know what i found
out though don't check this out this is
a fact i think i bet they have like
marie calendars or something right what
do they have in north korea uh chain
wrestling there's no chain restaurant in
korea dude
what they love we love a chicken papaya
no they don't have [ __ ] murray
california they do that there's no way
they have it there dude you don't think
they have a mickey yeah yeah we like the
mecca
is that a mcdonald's in north korea i
think it's like their version but you're
right they don't have like fast food
they don't have fast food there no
corporations go there what yeah dude i
finally imagine the home cooking
it's all home cooking bro i i i want to
say a couple of things about some things
i know about north korea no but check it
out dude number one meat is hard to come
by
right and sometimes they eat people it's
sad right
and then the second thing is did you
know
that they have factories there
they only make crystal meth
jeez and you know what they you know
what they give the workers their
compensation what like boxing gloves
no
have you seen that meth boxing
they gave them more math oh as their
like work compensation
so that which is smart because it's like
they just keeps them working
and then what they do is they they take
all this crystal meth they put them on
these boats and then they go to the
philippines and then to these dogs and
they you know they and then you know
it's shipped to black markets and you
know
countries black markets
like what do you mean
what do you mean like black one i mean
like
oh yeah i'm not oh no i'm not saying
this no
oh i see what you're saying
but you think that it's like at avons in
compton you mean like fam dollar
no no black market is the thing where
it's like you know what i mean um
i don't know how to explain it it's like
underground marketplace oh okay
like a dark alley or something
maybe it could involve that you know i
mean but like you know human trafficking
is in the black market oh damn damn you
know man but i guess if yeah i guess if
i'm being if i'm human trafficking or do
being human trafficked i would probably
want to have meth
yeah if you were with kim jong-un though
and he said i do honestly he goes you
both are gonna die
unless you suck it
who would go first
well let me think for one second
i would go first
bro i know i'm volunteering what because
i i dude i can't have the dude no
i can't have him anywhere around me i
heard him nuts early dude
they shoot those missiles at any hour
for no reason oh you think he would you
think i would go first and he would not
and and he'd look at you and go no need
i mean he did the job
you know how angry i'd be
i would just be like what the [ __ ] you
know imagine
god damn i did too good i did ball work
or whatever you'd be like a little
squirrel dude
i'm just saying boy if you catching that
damn jaundice nut out there
out in no co bro yeah that's but bro if
you took that semen and saved it inside
you that would be our movie
what do you mean you get kim jong-un's
seed
and i have to hold it in my mouth yes
because we have to get it out of the
country bro how long it seems like a
couple of days oh look bro bro it seems
like a couple of days we have to have a
plot dude you have to have at least like
yep i mean enough to have a good like
story arc all right how about this
i'll keep it in my mouth
but i'll give you three hours to out i
can only keep it in my mouth for three
hours i think oh come on do i have to
breathe huh well we can uh we could get
you one of those oxygen tanks yeah
oh you what do you mean huh yeah yeah
one of those like this little and we'll
uh with the on the little stroller you
stick the things in the the accent tubes
and then you uh you take electrical tape
and just zip my mouth together well we
can make sure you have to we also have
to kind of pinch your throat so you
don't swallow because dude if we get
that bro oh
oh imagine dude we're on the trunk
accidentally oh my god you hit a bump
i'd be so [ __ ] mad at you then we'd
have to get it out of your stomach dude
that's this whole thing is the movie
because if we get that dna
then we can create another one of him
why would we want to do that let's
create a daniel day cam or jimmy oyang i
mean
i don't know because i think then you
send that one there oh
make him
we have his son and it's like this is
your son and he wants peace
wow
we would have to grow that one fast
though we could do it
you see what you're saying to me is okay
let's just do the scenario take it over
to elon bust he'll grow it right we go
to his palace okay we do the
introductions right now first the first
two days when we get there we're gonna
have to party our balls off dude so
we're gonna lose our sobriety we have to
wear like robes and stuff probably
all the way i would lose my soprani for
that i would are there like yeah there's
so many different scenarios there's like
ten scenarios where i would lose it and
that's one of them that's one yeah yeah
it would be sucky though i would feel so
sad partying with you in north korea but
we'd bring a big book with us and do a
meeting every now and then
but we're drunk
yeah but we tried you know
okay so we're there we're partying for
two days oh yeah we're wearing robes
dude and everybody's and look dude none
we don't know what anybody's talking
about right look they keep talking to me
and i pointed you to translating you
don't know what they're talking about
yeah yeah yeah yeah then we go to the
now do we volunteer blowing him or does
he we wait for him to i'm not gonna
bring it up
yeah i'm gonna either i'm not gonna
bring it up but uh what do i do it's
part of the movie i think you gotta know
it's coming no i'll do this
just keep your mouth open a lot a little
bit i would like we're having like a
coffee with them
not full on but just you're just subtly
you know i mean you look i love your
palace and i go
yeah right
what is that yeah but i feel
something down below yeah
and i keep going
right yeah and sometimes i'll do this
i bet he's got that little pickled corn
thing bring up one of those
pickled corns
you know what i'm talking about oh man
that little thing that they put some
time in a damn drink or something at a
fancy place
right there
third row sixth pitcher
sets fifth
oh baby pickled corn oh wow that's six
that's what it is
yeah dude
do you think that's what it looks like i
think he's got that dirty little amber
jack on him
yeah yeah oh yeah dude so then he would
go after dinner coffee he'd go like okay
you both blow who go first i i would
volunteer well i think we'd have to draw
we have to do something to make it so
then that's part of the movie where it's
like how is it gonna happen oh we have
that like competition yeah something
we'll do a montage of competitions okay
you know i mean we're picking straws or
sticks or you know the thing like a
decathlon yeah yeah and then we cut two
we're on a track and we're running yeah
you know cut two we're like you know i
mean
doing hurdle just one you're doing one
hurdle yeah yeah and then i lose
obviously and we cut to
i'm blowing him i pep talk you but
you're in the corner i can't do it with
you in the room
what if i hide behind him
i'll be able to see you
dude imagine dude it's like enough
pressure
it's humiliating for me i'm sorry man uh
what if i'm trying to think where i
could i'll give you i'll tell you where
you're going but if i'm not in the room
i can't believe it that it happened oh
that's true okay
i'll let you be in the corner of the
room on a chair
yeah and i'll wear something different
you don't even know it's me yeah yeah
how about this you put a sheet over and
you're like we'll cut out the hole oh
come on no because i want a whole kkk
vibe
uh that'd be weird but if it helps you
man you'll help me it'll help me then
i'll do it right right so then i do it i
hold it in my mouth right
and i go then you have to talk from now
on oh yeah i cannot talk from now on yes
yeah yeah it's like see no evil here no
evil bring that up
give me the gene wilder uh richard pryor
movie yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
bring it up right here just click on it
yeah click on it dude i love that movie
dude yeah one of them is blind and one
of the deaf rights click on there we go
yeah yeah there we go it's a weird movie
yeah one of them's blind and one of them
is deaf right
so um god it was a good movie i love
that movie so um
i'm holding in my mouth you're doing all
the talking right and now i gotta get us
out of there right and he goes it's
bedtime it's bedtime boys so now we have
to go and he wants us to sleep in his
bed right
no
because we gotta sneak out of there ah
okay okay
so we gotta sneeze how about this how
about this all right
i get a bill cosby pill okay you know
because i know a guy all right that has
a [ __ ] it's about i can get into his
medicine cabinet okay he has these
purple pills right yeah you put one of
these cosby pills in his drink okay
because i need i can't have him like
yeah but i can't have him like i'm not
tired i'm going to watch
movies on my ipad yeah he probably will
too i bet he wears a diaper too yeah
yeah you're just sitting there just
hoarding morning right oh so we got to
get that guy out
right right so you have to if you don't
do that i'll be so mad i'll sing them
i'll be like hush little baby don't say
a word
in korean
[Music]
you have a plane ready huh why can't i
just dude let me just can i just have a
plane ready yeah let me ask you
something yeah go on why can't i just go
put it in my mouth
go i gotta go to the bathroom and spit
it into a jar oh no or like a little
receptacle why do i have to keep it in
my mouth because you have to keep it in
a condition where it would actually be
able to live
i know but what if i have like i could
probably go to elon musk or somebody and
go can you make me a [ __ ] [ __ ]
receptacle for kim jong-un
that's going to keep the [ __ ] alive
i guess i still understand why i have to
keep it in my mouth the whole time
i don't know why i had to blow the dude
that's true that's a good point
that's a good point that's a good point
that's a good point but since you did i
did i should keep it in my mind we gotta
make a movie about it all right all
right so then we gotta get you out of
the country oh here's how you do it
don't they not eat pork or something can
you google that up no they eat pork dude
what animal don't they eat we can
disgust every animal
there's not an animal they don't eat
because we could disguise you as that
animal right
oh i see
well you could disguise me as like
oh panda's half hacky how about a red
panda
ooh because they were extinct right no
there's a couple around so yeah so you
would be like an endangered species yeah
yeah a red panda yeah right
and so i'm wearing the outfit i still
have it on my cheeks right right
and i'm like i can't communicate and
you're gonna be losing weight too
because you're not gonna be eating
for how long do i have it in my mouth i
mean it's gonna take at least probably
72 hours to get to the border
well yeah we're gonna have to do a lot
you can't make me laugh oh that's true
you can't make me laugh you can't no
emotion okay it's just focus
yeah yeah i get in the thing locked in
like john peterson just like yeah jordan
peter yeah we'll listen to jordan
peterson on tape that'll motivate me
yeah and rom das ooh i like rom das
more spiritual just keep expanding
yeah i like ron dodson yeah he's good
right and then we get to the border then
i can spit it out we have scientists on
the other side oh they're waiting oh
they're waiting i spit it out
and i need listerine
i don't know if they have that in south
korea they have listerine they have they
have some some form of the thing
100
okay yeah they they [ __ ] clear their
mouths there okay cool all right yeah so
you got listerine now you're cleaned out
and you're back right and now we come
back to america and we are heroes dude
and now we have to raise him in the
sequel i know in the sequel we raise
them but we have to raise them fast
because you're saying that we have to
replace a grown
we got to grow ours
to replace him we can't have a kid go up
there and replace him
right so we have to have some we have to
put fertilizer i don't know how they do
it we got to grow them faster yeah way
to go how do we grow them fast i don't
know rice balls i don't know
i don't know i don't know what you mean
maybe a lot of rice balls i don't know
i've seen people that eat a lot of rice
krispie treats dude
and they're i mean
they're just fat i think i think the
movie needs work yeah yeah yeah you're
right
liam neeson
we're so close with a [ __ ] great
movie oh yeah we just need a little you
know yeah dude [ __ ] that's alright we
got time to think about how do you think
this movie is doing that you and i are
doing i think it's interesting man i
mean first of all it's been interesting
to do a movie for me and i wasn't going
to do it unless you did it which is kind
of you know under the wire huh i know we
were calling each other like every five
minutes going are you gonna do it are
you gonna do it are you gonna do it i
don't know i don't know i don't know and
we're doing it i just feel like it's i
feel like it's right the cast is right
and i just feel you know what i'm proud
of you because you're killing it oh
thanks you really are
thanks and i um
obviously because you haven't done a lot
of movies right yeah so there was like
kind of like what is he going to do but
you're like being real being very funny
and um
i think this will be good man you do oh
yeah if it sucks i saw that [ __ ] last
take what johnny did and i watched the
camera
it looks so cinematic really oh my god
it looks so good
dude your character's so
crazy yours is too
why is mine kind of crazy i i mean he
just like
he's just here though yeah yeah he's
been through so much though i know
but yeah dude i think um
that scene with the
chicken wings is hilarious so ridiculous
i watched from that uh editor thing or
whatever yeah yeah where like you're
chasing the guy and stuff yeah
we'll see what happens man but yeah man
i think
yeah it was so funny because on friday
we'd be like let's talk a money and see
if we want to do it and then on monday
one monday we're like oh we're not doing
it dude and then yeah yeah it's monday
we're in yeah yeah yeah yeah it's weird
i just feel like it was like kind of
meant to be i don't know i like the guy
live yep and it's about a sober living
large is the director and he wrote it
it's fun man look it's fun and i'm glad
i get to try and just learn it around
you because it's like you know you
wouldn't let me mess up if i was really
doing bad no and
johnny knoxville is in it mo amer
it's interesting yeah well aim or who
else
um oh gabe
gate is cool yeah
jade is crazy is it like dumbfounded
yeah yeah who's better looking me or
dumbfounded
oh i don't know
probably him i think
it hurts
does it really a little bit but you know
what in a different way you're better
looking more in like a historical way
old
i wouldn't say old i would say
you're very like
i feel like you have that look that has
been through time
yeah that just because i'll tell you why
we went to club last night after the
store did y'all he goes let's go to this
korean club
you guys went yeah i went and do y'all
always do that what is it like what's it
like when you see another korean dude
they would have loved you there but if
you see another korean do you know
immediately that they're korean
what do you mean like do you know
well he has a friend that looks filipino
so sometimes you don't know i mean his
he had like you know i mean
monkey eyes oh he had all of it yeah
yeah you know he had the filipino round
eyes
they were bulging out you got the you
guys got those crescents baby yeah we
have crescents right so him i was like
you're korean i am and i go wow that was
shocking but it looked good i'm not
saying i'm not making fun of him i look
handsome you know i mean yeah but i went
to the club and there was this um
guy who that day had performed in front
of 60 000 people
and his name is jay park he's like this
huge korean
rapper singer wow right so i was there
at his table right he's a huge fan i
don't know why
he's back in when he was everybody loves
you when he was a kid he watched mad tv
or whatever it might be but so i sung
out with the table but i realized that
night i'm never going to get laid again
really yeah cause the women they don't
look at me
they think that i'm like their
accountant
really do i'm being real dude an
accountant where dude on like a shipping
dock or something
like a wooden
wooden shipping dock no i'm like a i'm a
accountant for like you know uh bungie
the you know gaming company for what
like a kind of i feel like it would be
like hey kind of like
you would be accountant for like sex
trafficking or something
yeah but still an accountant nonetheless
but they look at me like like not in in
a viable way oh yeah they look like you
know oh no not you you know what i mean
i just kind of feel it so it's like i
might be alone for a while bro
i'm happy about it i don't i don't give
a [ __ ] but do you show up because here's
sometimes this can happen to you show up
to a thing it's like a night it's like a
festival not festive night people are
excited and you show up with kind of
like this i get scared in those type of
environments kind of and i show up with
a lower energy and so then i i seem like
the weird guy you know i think yeah i do
have a weird because i can't do by bobby
my bobby leeiisms in a club environment
you know i mean because it's loud people
are walking around so i'm just kind of
like
you know like biting my nails and i'm in
the corner i'm in the table i'm like
where i'm at the table where everyone
wants to be right finally i get to the
table but now i'm like the dad yeah i
mean so i'm just sitting there and you
know all these girls wanted to take
photos with jay park right and
dumbfounded right
and everyone saw a dude it's always a
dude some older korean dude i'm a big
fan oh right to me and i'm like oh god
you have a dick dude oh my god this is
so sad you know what i mean yeah yeah
but it's like when they're older and
what are they wearing usually
khakis oh golf shirt
khaki's golf shirt right oh
god
perm
you know koreans perm there yeah korean
dudes perm their errands pull it up
rodney yeah korean perm yeah korean guys
perm their hair oh all my uncles did it
they all got their perms yeah because
they didn't want to they didn't like the
straight a's
korean guys korean male perm do male
wow like that dude down there
and korean a lot of korean women look
deceased don't they in the
skin tone
they have a very deceased looking tone
on them like that guy right down there
in the third row
who is he yeah the red headed kid like
right there six oh to the left one more
anyway that guy right there he had that
wow like old korean dudes do that too
like jack hollow yeah they want to like
you know what i mean yeah they want to
look different you know i mean but they
do huh yeah when it's like if you ever
go to korean spa
we have straight pubes
really yeah it's like your dick isn't
shock oh my god it's always like ah you
know what i mean and the hairs come out
yeah yeah they don't really like if i
plucked one out right now you wouldn't
think that that was from my [ __ ]
genitalia area oh my god yours curl
yeah mind curl mine kind of seem
i mean they seem anxious i feel like but
they're curled yeah yeah most of mine
are curled probably from sheer anxiety
probably
but um you don't shave yours huh i trim
mine down can i just show you huh
yeah
oh wow
look at the bumper dude it's acne
damn brother that's pure acne
damn oh i thought that was the penis
no dude i rock harder than that dude oh
thank god dude if i would kill myself
that was my fault
would you kill yourself i mean it's a
pretty big zit
yeah
yeah dude if i had like that little red
bump as my penis i'll forget it i'd be a
monk what's the smallest a penis can be
can you bring that up for me brother
bear
what's a small they can be pretty small
bro
you do adult male 2 adult male yeah yeah
go to images smallest opinion is in
study about 1.6 one but images yeah
that's good images i'll see if they give
us anything
okay nothing
nothing
you know what's better put in micro
penis
really yeah i've just googled it before
why oh my god look at that dude what
look at that little one right there yeah
that that
wow bro
would you kill yourself
zoom in on that huh would you kill
yourself
okay wow
oh poor guy
right can you zoom a little more
wow look at that wow it looked like a
it's like a boiler it looks like it has
a little two eyes and a little face on
top it looks like a boiled peanut
doesn't it looks like a boiled peanut
dude oh my god oh my god imagine that
would be nice though you could probably
play with yourself and nobody would even
know yeah well you would you would just
rub it like a clue
you know i mean like you could that's
how you jerk out you just rub it like
that yeah
dude you have to have you to get a woman
with that penis you would have to be
jeff bezos
yeah that's what you would have to offer
i'll give you a mansion and a yacht
because this is nothing
you'd have to be elon bezos
[Laughter]
right what do you think about that zach
that weiner
uh it's a tough life for sure it's a
pretty tough life yeah yeah yeah i'm
sorry for the other image that was an
accident it's okay man it's dangerous
you understand it's dangerous ground
that google search so yeah yeah yeah
you know what i would do you know what i
would do with that
i would
i'll transition you would oh yeah i
would forget it i would just turn that
into a vag oh that's a great idea and
then you'd have the nicest little vagina
like
yeah it would be nice i would
all you would have to do is because
usually what they do when they do the
transition right is they take a penis
they cut it in half and they tuck all
the penis and everything inside the body
right but with that i wouldn't do that i
would just keep it as is yeah and just
build the vagina around it and that
would be my [ __ ] oh
[Music]
wow
you're i mean yeah yeah and just
imagining it's almost sounds like a very
it sounds like a delicacy
you know
yeah yeah
dude new man
so how about this you meet a great guy
right he's a cool guy who huh i'm not
telling you who he is because i don't
know who he is because it's just a magic
it's a magic person or made up fictional
so you meet a great guy he's really
really cool
um
you love him you end up falling in love
with him gay love yeah
and then he says delante
galente i want him to be delante jackson
delante jackson here yeah okay
so you're going yeah so lotto i know
what you're doing yeah yeah yeah he's a
mixed boy he's a mixed boy yeah and he
gets a
sex change do you still continue to see
him
wait i don't get the [ __ ] scenario so
what you're saying is i'm dating delonte
jackson
i'm not gay though
all right
that was a test
that whole thing was attacked i know
what you're saying to me is this
if i was dating a black girl by the name
of the lotto girl name um
delisha okay delisha jackson and she
goes i'm gonna be delante and i'm gonna
get the operation do you stay i would
leave you would
which
first of all
making a penis out of vagina is probably
so difficult really
because how unless they have a unless
you have unlit like a a lot of vagina
yeah i guess you cause what do you do
you borrow and put fat from your leg or
something yeah well you have to get a
lot you have to have a lot of vagina wow
yummy a lot of vagina meat because they
gotta really jangle that thing up yeah
they gotta jangle it up damn yeah yeah
and um i don't know what that's gonna
look like
also she's probably gonna take hormones
and her deep voices can get deeper yeah
or testosterone is that just
testosterone yeah and she's gonna grow
facial hair at that point it's gonna be
nah
right
i it's just tough because i don't know
what the future holds it's gonna like
chris spencer i don't know what the
future holds for you guys
i know nothing there is no future
if you haven't heard already it's smooth
sack summer
when you're playing in the summer sun
make sure you're escaped from pubes to
bum
that's right this is the summer to keep
your balls cool while still looking hot
with manscaped
keep your ding body looking good
what are you doing out there
and look i've been there i'm not judging
you
but sometimes i'll be dang naked just
damn baby naked
in front of a mirror and my damn wiener
and everything's all just you could be
my body's just falling apart the hair is
growing the weeds i got damn weeds under
my nuts
change it with manscape dive head first
in a smooth sack summer
and handle all your below the belt
grooming by going to manscape.com
for 20 off plus free shipping with our
code theo
that's true manscaped even throws in two
free gifts to their performance package
4.0 the manscaped boxers and the shed
travel bag that will bring your comfort
to another level
get 20 off and free shipping with code
theo at manscape.com that's 20 off plus
free shipping with code theo at
manscape.com it's smooth sack summer
boys get on board or get left behind you
know some of you might be sending a
child off to boarding school
you might be leaving your spouse or just
taking a vacation
with your family
well you may need another language when
you get there
you know you may need uh
to know a new language to communicate to
order a sandwich
to say hello to find a motel
well babel is the language learning app
that sold more than 10 million
subscriptions
thanks to babel's actively fun and easy
bite-sized language lessons
there's still time to learn a new
language before you reach your
destination with babel you only need 10
minutes to complete a lesson so you can
start having real-life conversations in
a new language in as little as three
weeks
with babel you can choose from 14
different
learn
languages including spanish french
italian and german
i like spanish there are so many ways to
learn with babel in addition to lessons
you can access podcasts games videos
stories and even live classes
plus it comes with a 20-day money-back
guarantee
right now save up to 60 off your
subscription when you go to
babel
b-a-b-b-e-l
dot com
theo that's b-a-b-b
dot com
slash t-h-e-o for up to 60 off your
subscription babble language for life
dude do you really think so because
you're saying you're living a single
life now
yeah
does it really bum you out or no
i'm sorry ma'am
um i just didn't know if it's tough
because you said you went to that the
party with the guy yeah i didn't go
there to meet women
you know i'm trying to like i know it's
hard when you get out in the world
because i'm sober so it's like usually
what i do is i'll do the clubs go
straight home and watch tv right
and now i'm going i'm 50 do i
go out and try to mingle
right so i went to the club you know i
mean also it's like you know with
dumbfounded
in a korean club you don't wait in line
right yeah i went into an elevator
zipped up right to the booth i mean it
was like
you know i mean the treatment oh yeah
right so i went up there and stuff and
it's all koreans in there
some happies too but mostly you you see
one white dude always alone at the bar
and what's he doing he's
really yeah and no one's talking to him
like a wook
yeah he's a wook dude
wow yeah dude that's the f that's what
the term is
i never knew what that term is and we
just created it we did yeah and a white
dude that wants to be an asian oh yeah
he's a wook yeah yeah yeah so there's a
wook at the bar these wings yeah yeah
these wings right
that's insane
safe but we're gonna go to chat no we're
not going to jail dude we're not okay no
no because we're just creating
terminology for the folklore yeah you're
right yeah for people you know we're
creating words oh there's nothing yet
some wink hanging around yeah well if
you're wearing a jeremy lin jersey yeah
it's just
right it's gotta stop yeah yeah and he's
got like a dragon ball z tattoo on his
arm you know i mean like weird right and
he's just like there right and he's got
like for some reason just extra boba in
his pockets
right just a loose mobile you know like
tater tots but he just uses boba and
eats it in his pockets right and he's
sitting there and like he you obviously
he likes asian women yeah he wants to be
asian yeah yeah it's like that one white
influencer who got his eyes operated on
to look asian no yeah you know i mean so
it's like who was that i don't know who
it was but a guy did that like he wants
to he's going for a white man he's a
white dude that wants to be asian and we
were a wook and we just created the
[ __ ] word man he's [ __ ]
yeah that dude
ollie london ali
london look at him
and is that is that frown is that or do
you guys accept these types of people in
the do asian people easily accept folks
like this into their culture or is this
considered a taboo move kind of what do
you mean except like he's not going to
be like
you know i mean if we have a ping-pong
tournament he's not invited i'm just
saying you got [ __ ] ramen dolazal
over here
and is that
accepted or not that's what i'm
wondering yeah um
i don't know like if i saw that dude
you know i mean roll up in the club i
would just be like i would be scared
yeah because he looks like [ __ ]
nicholas cage he looks like ms
he looks like emma uh msg mgk
[Laughter]
yeah yeah
yeah he doesn't look uh
he doesn't look asian
he doesn't look you know he looks like a
50 year old woman who just got botox
that's what she looks like right like
any 50 or 60 year old woman that gets
botox yeah go to that other pitcher
wearing the purple shirt down one yeah
down two down three
down more right there purple shirt
yeah yeah this honestly looks like this
beautiful girl named sarah that i dated
one time
yeah yeah yeah but that dude it's like i
think his parents are very disappointed
i should have been a better guy to her
but yeah i think her i think i don't
know what leads someone to want to be so
asian are they are they do you think
they're obsessed with the culture do you
think they're obsessed with the look
yeah people are really obsessed now like
of the culture because of
you know because you know korea has a
really cool musical scene you know what
i mean the k-pop song oh yeah it's huge
it's huge global you know i did a movie
with this guy henry lau
in thailand
and he would one time he goes hey come
to my hotel because he stayed at a
different hotel
and i walked over there and i saw
300 tents
of girls
sleeping outside this hotel wow and then
when i walked toward them people would
give me rice cakes right keep just the
henry right and i go i don't think he
likes rice cakes i think he likes [ __ ]
cakes
it's like if you have a [ __ ] cake
imagine me giving [ __ ] henry lau rice
cake
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] you know what
i mean so anyway i would bring rice
cakes to him and i'd be like people just
live there wow right and the kind of
power and i made the very big mistake
of so it was a movie i did with this guy
right and so i get a call going we're
doing a press conference in l.a
so it was like i'm not kidding you a
thousand kids mostly white
right
and
i i kept saying backstage i go can you
just bring me out first
no no no no no henry go up first oh
right and i bet i got on my hands and
knees
yeah i go please
just put me out first is that a cultural
thing or what is it you know because i
just knew what was gonna happen oh yeah
i mean yeah i knew what's gonna happen
if they said
bobby lee
i would get cheers yeah not a lot but
some right and then henry right but
that's not what happened
it went
henry
and when they said bobby lee you
couldn't hear it because of the [ __ ]
noise oh so i walked out and i got the
residual of his collapse
it was [ __ ] embarrassing dude
damn yeah it was terrible dude they're
like who's that accountant with him yeah
yeah yeah that's what i look like like
like his publicist yeah yeah oh it's
[ __ ] terrible but those people
have [ __ ] weight man
they're powerful dude why do koreans why
are they so uh why do they get so
do they do korean
get more obsessed with pop icons than
americans do
yeah but they're only obsessed with pop
right
like billy eilish you know um
harry styles like clint eastwood they
don't care they don't know who the [ __ ]
he is okay i mean they can't even say it
wow couldn't they would go couldn't
what god and i go eastward
right they wouldn't know wow like if you
told them like who's robert mitchum they
would not know
who's stephen robert mitchum he was a
deodorant guy no yeah he was an actor
for the 50th or any like any like like a
friend says i've been to korea right
they
no one knows who i am really dude it was
like being invisible like it reminded me
of what it was like in high school
just like oh no one knows me like when i
walk around in la i mean i get
recognized maybe it's not i don't live
for it but you were 10 15 20 times you
know what i mean you people go
love tiger belly this and that right i
don't feel as invisible right right in
korea dude they don't give a [ __ ] about
me
except for the artists
um like there's this guy named jyp who's
like the puff daddy of korea he he flew
me out there last time to do a music
video for him you know i mean i was in a
music video for a band called the wonder
girls dang yeah yeah so i flew off for
that so they requested me but all the
civilians they
i had to wait in line no one said hi it
was like
yeah no they don't give a [ __ ] that's
interesting it feels like what it was
like in high school that's such an
interesting uh comparison because the
whole reason i i don't want to get like
but the whole reason it's like
i don't know about you but
growing up and even in my early 20s i
felt
invisible
you mean like i remember i i i lived
with this guy named kalisto he was a
handsome mexican dude oh wow he sounds
like it yeah yeah and we would walk into
a bar
and i one time a woman just walked up to
him and started making owl on them oh he
didn't even say hi my name is do nothing
right and i walk in so invisible
you know i just felt like
i don't know like i didn't exist almost
right and then you just kind of pursue
this thing to like express yourself you
know yeah this comedy thing you know i
mean and it's like i finally got to the
point you know i mean where you know i
don't feel as invisible i feel like i'm
a part of the world i guess you know
it's so sad to even think that i even
need to do all this to feel that way you
know what i mean
it is but it makes sense though man
especially what you're saying it's like
i can really relate to that it's like
you feel invisible
oh man i realized that like like my mom
never like looked at me very much or she
just worked all she was gone um and my
dad wasn't around so yeah i think
i felt like nobody ever saw me like man
nobody even knows nobody that i care
about or anything even knows who i am
you know yeah like i would give anything
i think as a like a child give anything
for somebody to just look at me
you know
like man if somebody would have just sat
and looked at me yeah it's like would i
even have done this job sometimes i
think about that no i honestly if i had
like um
like i feel like normal parents that
like listened and
goes how do you feel today or i mean i
adore you i adore you or give me a hug
or any of that right i don't know i'd
probably be different
yeah i'd probably be like you and i
would probably be working for
you i mean
amazon
in the warehouse delivery guys delivery
guys or something yeah but we would have
a woman we would have kids
paying mortgage
that sounds horrible though huh i don't
know if it sounds horrible it sounds
hard though
it sounds really hard especially given
the way that you go like it sounds so
hard for me to like get in it's like
it's been so hard for me to trust like
the affections of anything in the world
like really you know it's like
so i i've always had that issue of like
i used to say sometimes that i would if
i if i jumped off a cliff if i heard a
woman's high heels like
i would find a way to get back up just
to see her like
wait no no no doesn't make any sense so
you're
you're on the golden gate bit bridge
right and you're about to jump off
because you kill yourself and i do jump
you do jump in mid air you see you hear
high heels
you do what princess leia did in that
one movie and just go back to the ship
i would find a way to find i would find
a way to get back up just to see if that
woman would give me attention yeah
like i would find it's like there's
something inside of me that would give
anything to have and it doesn't even
have to be like sex it just has to be
some sort of
attention like a a look or just to see
if they see me yeah i see a girl that's
saying i see you
you matter and um i care about you
yeah even if she says look i don't like
it but i see you yeah that i see i would
even accept that yeah i would accept
that too yeah like hey you're not my
fave but yeah i see you bucko you know
that i can almost live with yeah
do you really you don't feel like you
had that as a kid huh
no i mean i tell this story sometimes
where um
and this this really kind of um
sums up
my childhood um
when i was eight years old we lived in
minnesota really yeah edina minnesota
really
because you know what else happened up
in there
yeah highway to heaven bro i get it dude
and i lived in edina minnesota dover
drive was my street
and i remember i didn't have a lot of
friends
so one day i went i was like eight years
old and i go
mommy daddy
could i have a pet
and they go oh what kind you know i go a
cat
so they get my cat a kitten
and i remember that summer um i get
emotional even thinking about it
i named him tom because it's like i
didn't know anything else tom and jerry
was a thing back then so it was good
yeah so i named tom and i remember being
in the garage
because that he wouldn't be led in the
house we got had like a little pen
in the garage and i would play with him
all day long for weeks
and then one day i
left
i came home and tom was gone i was
freaking out
where's god what's up and my dad looks
at me goes
he's no longer here
i go what happened i put a pound
no and i go why mommy allergic
and then i started crying and they go
stop crying
and then they left the garage and i
remember sitting there
tears
there's no voice like you know no
compromise no how do you feel you know i
mean nobody can reason why no reason why
there's no there's i there's no voice
right and i just had to take it
i was powerless
right
and i just um
that sucked my upbringing in a nutshell
like i just felt like no one heard me
and so that's why i learned to act out i
learned to like you know be funny and um
do [ __ ] but it's like that's why i have
seven animals now wow you know i mean
because it's like i
i love you know i love animals so much
and it's like i don't know i just i'm
just compensating for that you know i
mean i don't know what happened to that
kid
that that cat but it's just like
it just sums up like why i am the way i
am i think you know
i get so angry even thinking about it oh
dude you know man yeah
and when he died two years ago
[ __ ] how long did he live for until he
was 80. and i loved the man i do i love
your father my dad oh you mean you were
thinking about the cat i thought tom
i'm sorry
that's really funny dude i'm sorry yeah
my dad jeremy
when he died i remember like
just looking at my brother and my mom
they're just
bawling you know i mean
they're just on the ground rolling
around you know in tears you know i mean
and i literally was just looking at not
a tear in my eye
i was numb i was like
this is [ __ ] weird what do i do
so i put sunglasses on because i knew my
uncles and aunts were coming in right
because i wanted to pretend like i was
like emotional about it but it's like i
didn't feel anything and it's like i
love him and i miss him but it's like i
know i just have all these unresolved
like feelings toward him you know
and that's you know it's like i i would
never do that
to my own child you know i mean
never he also beat us and all that stuff
but it's just like i don't know man
it's weird i haven't really fully worked
it out but i mean there's reasons why
i'm so [ __ ] up i think you know man
yeah man i'm sorry that that happened to
you
i really am no yeah it's like that kind
of shit's heartbreaking man that like
stuff like that happens to kids
um
do you think because i have things like
that too man sometimes there's like so
much anger built up inside some days i'm
a lot of times i'm okay and then
sometimes i'm so angry
you know what i got i finally realized
the other day while i was angry i
realized
because i've always had like a lot of
like
anger against i think against my mother
i didn't really know my dad that good so
my mother's the only parent left
and uh
i get angry and honest because she
missed out on me that's what i feel like
yeah like she missed out on like
whoever i was or whatever
was unique about me or not unique or
whatever my feelings were like she
missed out on all of it you know oh yeah
it just she's still alive right yeah
she's like i've seen photos with her
yeah um
do you help her like if she needs help
and stuff yeah yeah i help her out you
know like with i help support and stuff
like that you know i'm grateful that my
mom i think she did the best she could
and i think it's like it makes me sad
also that
my mom probably got treated that you
know she only knew what she needed it's
a cyclical thing it's so funny it's a
cyclical thing because my parent my
parents had it worse when they grew up
oh way [ __ ] worse
you know i mean i mean i could tell you
[ __ ] crazy stories that they told me
but it's like
you know but here's the thing theo
i literally still wouldn't change it for
the world
because without all those past
experiences right i wouldn't be who i am
now
and i think i'm pretty cool you know i
mean i mean i'm a [ __ ] up guy but it's
like you know i honestly look in the
mirror and i go you know what dude you
i'm so proud of myself
for some of the things that i persevered
through you know i mean this business is
hard
you know i mean there's a lot of
rejection and a lot of like am i gonna
make it and this is years
you know now you know you have the
internet and you know people do tick
tock videos and they do different ways
to make money but when i was coming up
right you had one way you do the clubs
you become a opener feature headliner
you get tv spots hopefully you get a
sitcom and that's pretty much it yeah
right and it's like i
just so proud that i was like i came to
la with no money i didn't know i didn't
know anybody from show business and i
crawled my way to where i am now and
there's you know there's a resilience to
that i think you know i mean i always
downplay it and i have low self-esteem
but it's like um but at the today i i'm
a [ __ ] warrior yeah in a weird way
right yeah yeah it's like i did
something because
a lot of you know people that have had
my kind of upbringing they turn to drugs
they don't get sober
they they perpetuate their behavior and
they become shitty dads themselves or
whatever it might be you know i mean but
it's like i chose
to you know
get sober frequently during my life and
um try to read books to help better
myself to be a good guy you know what i
mean you haven't given up
i'm not going to give up you never give
up on yourself yeah no no and um the
resilience of it but it's like it's a
tough business and um
so i wouldn't change anything for the
world would you
um let's be real because you're theovan
yeah i think it's well i just think it
just goes back to that one thing that
it's like
uh
if i didn't need
attention if i didn't need like i
remember a lot of my high school
girlfriends and stuff i kept i'm still
keep in touch with their mothers you
know what do you mean like i'm still
friends with their mothers oh yeah yeah
like friends with them yeah like even
more than i talk to the girls it's like
there was just such a pattern you know
it's like i just wonder like if i would
have been yeah i would have been
different but so sometimes i think that
makes me sad but uh
no i don't think so man i think it's
probably the same for you it's like
i chose like
if something in the world isn't gonna
see me then i'm gonna take the hardest
thing the world has supposedly which is
stand-up comedy and i'm gonna [ __ ]
[Music]
make you see me you know yeah i'm gonna
make you see me it's almost sometimes i
think i needed everybody in the world to
love me just because i wanted to get my
mother to love me it's like i just
figured eventually wow it will get back
to her yeah and then i'll
feel some type of way you know and i'm
not trying to get into self-pity either
i got to be aware of that because i get
in a self-pity no yeah yeah no yeah but
i think man you're a dude there are
times people come up take a picture like
can i get a picture with you and then
like can you try and look more like
bobby lee in the picture they will
literally want me to be like they're
like can you squint a little can you
uh
can you not really yeah you look more
fat can you
can you dress like you sell timeshares
at a carnival
they're like can you help me yeah yeah
yeah
do i get girls going you are the most
beloved
i have girls on my dms going you're all
right but can you introduce me to theo
oh yeah
and it's like everywhere i go it's like
i don't know a single bobby lee fan that
isn't a huge theofon fan yeah it's like
i feel like you and i
kind of cross
we're very similar in many ways don't
you think or no
well i think especially in this way like
even we're just talking about you know
yeah it's like that's one thing i s that
i know in you is that you know we both
have this similar
a lot of issues with women
yeah and
um
yeah wanting to be seen and people that
love us like you have so many friends
man it's like you too and it's like you
know um
listen
i don't want to
talk about the past
i i just want to say that
i believe i i honestly i think my life
would be not as cool without you in it i
i
you know watching you rise
becoming friends with you and um
i don't know just watching you have such
a unique voice and to see it blossom
i just saying that i just feel like
everything happens for a reason and
you're around this people certain people
for a reason and it's like um
i know i just wouldn't change any of
this you know i mean even your best
friend brendan schaub you know me people
online are like you know i mean do you
hate brendan what's going on there or
there's like people attacking me because
of that little thing that i had on with
brendan and then they you know i mean at
the end of the day it's like i love
brendan i love you i love everyone you
know i mean we just had a little
conflict you know i mean but at the end
of the day i wouldn't change
any of it for the world you know even my
breakup with kalila it's like you know
it's just a part of life
and you know we broke up in the most
loving way possible because i love her
and she's in many ways the love of my
life you know she really is i love her
um
more than i've ever loved anyone else
you know i mean um she's a part of my
life and you know if i
if i was sick kaleido would be the first
person to be by my bedside you know and
vice versa you know so um
i know i just wouldn't change it you
know i i was a little depressed earlier
today but you know um
yeah we still wouldn't change anything
really how about you
honestly man every time i hang out with
you i feel
like
i feel lucky let's don't be this that's
what i feel like dick sucking fast uh
you already blew a [ __ ] emperor dude
for no reason
if all we're doing now is
if we're if we've notched down a verbal
blow job at least we're doing better
yeah but no man every time around y'all
feel lucky to be around yeah yeah it's
cool and i think the world and we i
think this we should get this is a good
opportunity to force fox
yeah [ __ ] fox
okay so i want to let people know yeah
theo and i and just let's just talk
about this real quick okay all right so
we get a call
what a year ago yeah
we if you and i separately get a call a
year ago
from fox the network fox the network
right and they're like the president of
fox yeah our huge bobby lee theovon fan
and he would like to see both of us
together
on a tv show and we're like whatever we
don't you know i mean we don't even know
if it's real or not but one day
we have to zoom with him yeah one day we
got to zoom with the man with the man
and the other women too
great women nice people everybody very
nice people yeah yeah the best but
i remember 10 minutes before the pitch
we called each other and we're like
what are we gonna what's our idea what's
our idea and we came up with it yeah we
came up with two
in 10 minutes yeah you remember that
yeah
and then we think
oh this is not gonna work but we went
into zoom
and we pitched it
and they like really liked one of them
yeah and they gave us
they gave us a deal yeah they gave us a
deal to be detectives detectives and we
um but the deal hasn't closed we don't
know what the [ __ ] is going on it's been
eight months it's been eight months we
want to get going on it yeah right or we
will oh we'll take it somewhere else
yeah so fox either get it or not get it
or not get it yeah yeah and i'm serious
[ __ ] seal this [ __ ] thing yeah
because we don't want to do it because
it's some place we want to do it because
we want to do something together yeah
you know yeah we want to do something
together you know man and if a place
supports us then that's awesome and
we'll support them i think i do feel a
little unsupported that it's taking this
long it's not this is the way these
things work
that's why i don't do that kind of [ __ ]
but i would with you though
well i mean
the whole reason why we're doing it
because we want to go to hawaii yeah
that's true so our whole thing was this
we're like whatever it is
we just make it hawaii
[Laughter]
right because i just imagine like even
if it's shitty right we're in [ __ ]
hawaii you know what i mean and then you
and i could pod there or whatever
but like you know hawaii definitely you
know i mean yeah two single guys in
hawaii with a tv show oh oh my god
crying at night in a meeting yeah yeah
eating catsu all night and [ __ ] you
know what i mean whoa no cat for me
yeah yeah okay we're not yeah yeah yeah
it's different because it's different
yeah sure it is
doesn't sound sick
it doesn't sound super different man
yeah yeah dude that [ __ ] with brendan
though was [ __ ] crazy that was like
the worst game of clue i'd ever seen in
the world when you guys did that thing
it's like he had like these fought the
files and the full and you guys had like
missing people in the [ __ ]
there was some guy beating kids on
reddit yeah yeah yeah how do you i can't
even get into my reddit how do you beat
kids yeah like the that was the [ __ ]
the whole thing was unbelievable the
whole thing was unbelievable and i was
just like you know i don't
i don't want this [ __ ] to be [ __ ]
happening
but it was [ __ ]
i don't know it was pretty [ __ ] yeah
the whole it was i mean the things they
were saying was like i had i wouldn't
even i didn't even know what the [ __ ]
they were talking about i was like
what reddit and what's going on you know
and they got you're the one
i'm the one what
i mean i don't have a computer
and then it's like i remember like
here's the funny thing brendan doesn't
own a computer
i know i know he doesn't own a computer
he doesn't and then i remember dalia
calling me and going delia goes you
don't own a computer and i go
i know
right he doesn't know that yeah he
thinks i'm i don't even know how to log
into anything you know anyway you know i
mean and i saw him i've seen it a couple
times and i've been very cordial you
know i mean hopefully you know we can do
this you know i mean and and get back
but oh you don't take a while i think oh
i think you guys are i mean it's i've
never heard him have any animosity i
don't think he ever does yeah yeah
vernon never really does have any
animosity towards anybody yeah yeah um
which is crazy to think that he came
from a fighting world where they had
that so much animosity that's something
that's always interesting about him but
um
he's one of the hardest workers that i
know but that whole thing was just
[ __ ] absolutely [ __ ] i'm like is
everybody [ __ ] and now it's like it's
like it was like the game of clue though
it was like somebody did it in the
[ __ ] yeah yeah in a mop closet a bad
server yeah yeah yeah i i didn't even
know you know yeah it was also like i
was at the time when they made the calls
i was on set shooting something and
although it was like it really just the
timing was really weird and it's like
whenever somebody's like you know accuse
me of something i didn't do right it
feels like
traumatic almost like because it's like
the way they were talking you know i
mean it's like you know they were like
no
bully is the wrong word but they were
just really adamant about it and they
had a lot of feelings behind it well
they believed it i don't think people i
think these kind of maybe still do i
don't know well i don't think they was
making it up
you think they still believe it
i don't know
i don't know i feel like they still
believe it vernon and i haven't really
spoken about it much yeah i try not to
talk about it either but i don't know
but i thought the whole thing was just
holi i mean it was but it was
interesting too it's all it's all like
the world is just it's all this
it's all this crazy
just drama this play and we're just
taking
different paths through it it was
[ __ ] pretty you know but you know
what i kind of i would not change that
either because it's like you know
no we've been really lucky so lucky yeah
we're really lucky to [ __ ] and it's
funny because sometimes i used to think
man it's sometimes it's like i was like
man if i laughed more as a human
then i would be out in the crowd
enjoying the show sometimes i want to be
the guy in the crowd just having a good
time but i felt like i never even could
be that guy yeah so i had to be the
other guy
yeah yeah you're right like when i'm in
a show
are you having a good time i'm sometimes
i am
i look at the people in the crowd and be
like oh man i wish i had like the
patience and the
the just ability to sit and be
just
like enjoy something from someone like
sometimes i don't i struggle with that i
think or i don't know sometimes i'm
envious of the people in the audience
having a good time yeah i i definitely
have to force myself into doing things
because i'm trying to like
because i really want to change that
about myself you know because generally
i don't even show up to anything i see
you working on it man you've been doing
a lot of podcasts you're staying busy
you did the movie you're staying a lot
but not only that like i've been going
to like
like premieres it's like you know i mean
like i've like i've been invited to
premieres i've not gone to a single
[ __ ] wand bro
i just i i don't want to sit there i
don't know what to say around the people
yeah you get nervous but you get anxious
i get so anxious and then it's like but
what i've been doing to do this has been
working for me dude the last two years
what i've been doing is
because usually like when i'm like on
a set i go
in my head i go they know
they know i'm not talented or i go i
don't want to talk to the producers of
the director because i don't want to
burn any bridges you know i mean or if i
feel uncomfortable am i going to say but
i've done the reverse now i've gone up
to them i go what do you think of this
this is my ideas i become friends with
them i treat them like anyone else like
a [ __ ] comic or whatever right it's
gotten so much better for me wow yeah
yeah now i feel way more relaxed i feel
a part of the process dude when i did
[ __ ] harold and kumar mm-hmm
this is 20 years ago dude i had never
taken an acting class bro right and all
of a sudden i'm being flown to toronto
and i'm on set and there's i've never
seen cameras like that before and i had
some lines you know me some chunky
things i had to say
and i remember i spent three days in my
hotel room
writing every single word down
backwards and forwards so i wouldn't
forget and then when i was on the set i
remember i didn't talk to anybody and i
was petrified
i couldn't breathe and they would go
action and i would just do it you know
what i mean and then like i wouldn't ask
you know is that right should i do it
again you know what i mean i just was
not even there i wasn't even present
that's like meter and sex i feel like
they say action and i just do it real
fast
how long do you last oh man don't be
real oh
would say probably
four minutes
wow is that enough that's not enough
four minutes
maybe five maybe
what time of year is it
oh it depends if it's colder out i'll
stay in there
yeah
what you do is this my move
you go i'm about to come up about to
come and you pull out
yeah right and you know what they call
that
they call it
edging
oh yeah yeah yeah when you're about to
come and you don't do it you're on the
edge oh and then what do you do then you
you scare your neighbors
you pull out right and you go to the
bathroom you wash your face you let it
go down a little bit and you come back
for the second round and what are they
doing the whole time there do you put
the tv on or something no but let me
have the kindle maybe reading something
i don't know you know but like i i don't
i don't think i have a kendall
no but you what you do is you say you be
honest and this is yours i'm about to
come i don't want to come yet you pull
out i wouldn't you just go to the edge
of the bed and just give me a second and
you go back in and then you you know i
mean go to round two my point is is that
you don't have you have the you have the
opportunity to stop yeah or is it when
you're in there you just have to keep
going i feel like i'm like those thai
minors or whatever they couldn't get out
you know
it'll be the soccer team yeah yeah yeah
the chilean chilean miners who yeah yeah
yeah i mean them boys you gotta respect
them dude i know you know
they stayed in there i would have died
you think
dude
if i was that thai soccer team
and i was in amount like in the [ __ ]
caverns with water and stuff and imagine
you're claustrophobic okay
it's dark and now what i would probably
take you'd be the leader you tell me and
i'm gonna everybody else is kind of
sleeping or they're sick from the gas
all right there's no gap you tap me on
the show there's no gas huh why is there
gas there's methane gas in the bottom oh
there it is let's see it look at that
look at them pick out which ones
all right dude let's zoom in on these
boys all right yeah oh that's you on the
right
zoom in on that one on the far right
yeah that's me down
oh
but you know what i would be like i
wouldn't even be like that do you ever
see rambo two
rainbow two
yes rambo two and remember he hid in the
cliff mm-hmm right the soldier walked by
and his eyes popped out you thought it
was a part of the i would be like a part
of the cliff
okay but we to go we got to get out of
the cliff right and that would probably
undo myself okay okay
with you undo me right and you would
like scratch off the sand oh it's the
sand and dirt okay so you're hiding even
though it's just us down there
now i'm number 20 down over here the guy
that looks a little bit scared but he's
going to come through in the end right
there right there you're that guy yeah
let me see him zoom in on him a little
bit
let's let these boys live a little gang
no
no no that's us too in the back okay
let's see
no so i'm back at that those two right
there we're holding each other dude okay
right i'm the guy in the front you're
holding me in the back okay right and
then we're like
we're asian so what do we desire and
what pervert took this picture and
probably sold it online immediately
what if there's a pedophile that went
down there
oh sure dude i used to work at a summer
camp this man would take pictures of us
every day right i got a new job as a
security advisor or whatever counselor
yeah and so i'm out there with my crew
of kids five and six years old we swim
every day this man's taking pictures
this guy mr bill i'm talking to him and
stuff
so i go get paid on friday and i said
man when what is mr bill when do we get
to see any of those pictures and like
who the [ __ ] mr bill and i'm like the
guy that's taking pictures of us at the
pool every day and they're like we don't
have anybody mr bill really hundred
percent oh wow wow wow
do you think he was jerking off to your
phone we're all down there posing with
the pictures and do it all are you being
real yeah we had no idea yeah okay so
that's you and me we're in the cage yeah
why don't we get out
well you wake me up i'm sleeping
yeah yeah hey
tongo
is that your name in it um yes yeah
what's my name huh
uh ramrok
tango and ramrok yeah yeah
tango get up yes yeah
what are we gonna do oh ramrok
i don't know um i was sleeping
okay go back
right and then what i would do is i
would i would test the water
okay
every hour i would go
i dunk my head in to the because what
happened was they swam right right and
then the and then like what a swell came
in and filled all that up and they
couldn't get back right so i would test
don't tell what happens i don't know
what happens
what do you mean don't tell me what
happens with them i i know there's a doc
there's like i want to read it or
whatever when we get out of here but
keep going
i don't know what the [ __ ] happened to
them okay good yeah yeah yeah i don't
know the conclusion i know they lived oh
[ __ ]
you
you didn't think they lived oh you're
just like my ex-girlfriend you just
can't not tell you yeah
yeah they live bro
dude obviously they lived who took the
[ __ ] photo some it wasn't a pedophile
it was the people that rescued them
oh you think pedophiles are only above
ground dude you're out of your mind oh
there's a ground pedophile i think so
bro they do groundwork i'm sure they do
here's something about doing group work
oh wow uh no that was the rescue team
they took the photo
and then they're like what's up what's
up
this guy's gonna see him just like why
is he so mad this is asthma i think but
he seems like you know he's in a bad
mood or i just said he is this is how
when i came in here he didn't say he
didn't smile at me or nothing maybe
something's at something well i'm not a
big enough guest is that what it is i
was just checking the camera i know but
when i came in here in the first place
you weren't smiling or nothing i i'm
trying to focus on the thing i got
cameras got focused make sure the audio
is good i just you know
i'm excited personally
it's focused
um zach's been working here probably for
two months one year but yeah close oh
damn oh no my bad
he got bad
but as full time
yeah two three months okay there we go
so he wasn't that's what i meant that's
what he meant did he go to nashville
with you grateful to have him no he does
not um him and colin work here and i
would you know what i want to do is i
want to go to nashville oh you're not
coming back out here right yeah yeah i
am you're gonna move back out here oh i
don't know i'm gonna go test out austin
for one month in january when joe's club
opens up oh that's right
should i test it out too that would be
fun there's three stages there four
once his opens up do you want me to get
it
get it everybody for a month dude what
if you lived there for one month but can
we live together yeah
nobody tim dillon has a house
i'm i'm being real
aaron how do you say aubry
and airbnb
i think if you if it's from a black guy
it's airbnb
yeah you know like airbnb it's our b and
b yeah yeah so if we got a so we went to
austin for a month
airbnb right we would do spots around
town do shows do shows and
do you think that would be fun i think
that would be fun be cool
i i want to do a workout material do you
really yeah i really do i think another
month maybe two weeks okay else but get
out get up get an airbnb with two rooms
or whatever yeah or more than two rooms
yeah and one month i'll just get it for
a month
we'll get hit up 10 dinner and see he
has a house there yeah i know he does
that's something i'm sure it's nice he
has a cat he's like a k he's like um
somebody said he bought a limousine
yeah he's got money dude yeah yeah yeah
um let's look at a couple news stories
before bobby gets out of here man
yeah well big one is uh we had the kids
mullet championships happened this
weekend we had a lot of people posting
about this with you theo all right i
kind of want to look through some of
these guys if you want since bobby stole
my style a while back
um so we'll scan through some i know who
won but we'll scan through something
well can we judge or who won yeah yeah
all right
so i'll go start here hell yeah dude all
right this one's good dude
you know what i like about this one huh
doesn't bobby look like ron jeremy
though i gotta bring that up right now
if you don't play him in a biopic okay
dude you said that as an improv line in
the movie
and everyone laughed and it hurt my
feelings did it really
yeah because he's like an old fat
shriveled up man now he is but let's see
i'm gonna do ron jeremy 28 years old
he's still not that he's still he looks
like a machete
yep
okay can you find a decent looking
picture on now there we go there we go
get that [ __ ] so you think i look
like that right now god yeah all right
good well i can take that god yeah all
right dude i can imagine that stanger
you got in your pants boy yeah yeah i
mean you got something the cop asked for
your id just break that thing out god
he's in so much trouble right now though
bro every picture he's in he's like just
no but have you seen those prison shots
how sad it is look at the prison shots
really like the court shots
ron jeremy in court
oh where is he doing court at hannibal
lecter's house
i know dude bro that's his life
in prison
oh
man
that's what you get for ten thousand
[ __ ] oh that's the price of ten
thousand pesos that is huh yeah yeah the
price of ten thousand [ __ ] what a
great documentary yeah yeah the price of
ten thousand [ __ ] and that's what you
get you can't have that much
i feel like when a man gets too much
the universe just goes
you get them you know monkey pops you
know they do something we'll see you
yeah we'll see you yeah that's true
that's good you got to be moderated dude
you know what i mean i take what i need
i don't take more yeah right so that's
all right go ahead i agree last time i
gave a guy back some of the money he
paid me to do a set
yeah i said do you like this one or what
i think brock is coming in hot here i
think it's kind of a basic kind of
thicker one look at the side dude three
lines that fisherman's son look look at
the four lines on the side what does
that mean
i don't know but it's like if he did
that himself he's talented
i'm sure his mother did it oh here we go
oh callan uh he's got some accusations
against him but bro great guy though
also his hair's receding at that age
dude i don't know bro look
which makes it even more likely that
this is brian cowan
um yeah no i think that he's a beautiful
kid though oh here we go dude
i would dude that's my son i would love
that would you want that oh
dude that'd be great i would lift this
kid up i'd throw him so [ __ ] high in
the air he'd never come down or i just
give him tasks like go get the squirrels
yeah i mean okay tapa yeah right and
you'll go bring like three or four
squirrels
we'll boil them yeah yeah yeah dude
i love
oh catching now this dude definitely you
could tell he'll [ __ ] he's got something
in him yeah he's got something in him
dude you know he's young but i bet hold
on hold on man yeah let's go back to
[ __ ] jesus christ he's like you could
see in his eyes look at him yeah
he [ __ ] means business and then when
he gets older straight teeth oh he looks
like he took some of his teeth out
because he wanted to
he is a gangster boy let's see somebody
else he's out of lawton
oh [ __ ] okay jewish guy showing up out
of hogansburg in new york you think he's
jewish dude oh 100 italian i would say
actually i think he you know who he
looks like is the guy
man my brain's been so bad no you know i
know what you know to me you know what
she he looks like
uh what's that woman that was like oh
like she did them she was a madam for
the prostitutes uh
elaine maxwell no flies no heidi flight
heidi flies wow heidi fights that looks
like a young heidi flies ooh i like that
i like that yeah yeah yeah um
wait wait look it up heidi fl see
heidi flies yeah he doesn't fight he
flies five yeah heidi flies five as well
um and also he looks like uh who is the
famous podcaster that we've all been on
his show
adam
corolla on the left it looks like adam
crawford corolla dude yeah why can't
he's mexicans in that [ __ ] photo does
he i don't think adam likes mexicans
all right really yeah
i want to be mexican go on
please brother
oh emmett oh oliver tree
oh yeah yeah a young oliver tree dude he
took that straight out of that oak tree
yeah yeah dude
what's up ollie dude oh town or oh tree
pick one
what oh town oh town bro i don't know
what that [ __ ] means the band oh town
i never heard of it
all right bring up the next one m is
good though emmett's good
out of carthage huh
tim dillon dude oh yeah a baby tim
dillon oh this dude will suck start a
skateboard right here this little buddy
yeah adam minani wisconsin boy he's
gonna turn out to be a promoter
yeah like a brian monarch oh he's gonna
promote a damn honey bun into his pocket
i bet if he's smart i like it good luck
emmett
epic epic dude
what a cool name too
out of la joya texas yeah now this
almost seems i worry epic might be one
of those kids because it's that he goes
on to really live this lifestyle he gets
a motorbike next year right it gets
intense and he just you know it's a lot
of pressure and he could end up on drugs
yeah good luck bud good luck epic all
right let's see two more and then we'll
pick a winner here yeah
oh look at the tongue dude jack is cute
i don't like don't look at the tongue
dude that's weird yeah yeah yeah yeah i
look like i wasn't the photographer i
was like can you do one without tongue
i mean you're a kid why did the
photographer go we'll choose another one
you know what i mean
yeah okay yeah let's move on let's move
on dude just to stay legit over here
oh wow
and he almost looks honestly like he
doesn't want to be doing this yeah like
he was forced to get the haircut yep
yeah so i'm gonna vote no one jameson is
because they did this to him
yeah he won't even look at the you can
tell
or maybe it's like the second photo
could be like why'd you take the
sunglasses off me oh
a little bit but look at the mouth on
the first one and i'm not looking don't
look at the mouth never mind move along
that [ __ ] is bad dude oh this guy's like
[ __ ] 40.
[Laughter]
you can't have a 40 year old in there
dude yeah yeah yeah
yeah and let's still dude we all we all
know this guy's scottish and not
american yeah yeah this dude is
definitely looks like one that's william
wallace bro
this guy that's [ __ ] straight up
braveheart dude
this guy looks like one of the
characters in the newsies let's keep it
moving yeah yeah let's keep it moving
oh
yeah
this dude will sell you some [ __ ]
land in his bedroom bro
yeah yeah yeah
i'm out on lincoln yeah he seems like he
took it in the sun too this almost seems
like he's not so things aren't going to
work out well
latino huh you think it's latino my son
i don't know dude really fremont yeah
this dude definitely is hugging i want
to just tug the back of that he knows
somebody that's picked the damn
strawberry i'll tell you that bro
beautiful guy mess on actually looks
like my mother a little bit beautiful
onward
how many are there he's getting so many
there's more i can tell
there's more i could tell you the winner
if you want you wanna know the winner uh
bring up my favorite one
emmett the other emmett
oh no the other what was the other one
parkinson's or whatever his name is
what's his name we have ruston emmett
and bailey rustin
bring up the little guy i like the first
one i told you if you don't mind
right there in the middle on the bottom
rusting nope right there bam that's a
good one dude
this little we never even saw that one
this tater hunter right here little
rusting yeah that that's a good one from
pocahontas arkansas yeah look at him
doing work right there he's already
working dude i love it changing a tire
dude on his house that looks like a meth
lab yeah
yeah all right who do you think won
i dude i i mean um
i'm gonna go with the oliver tree hair
wow with the [ __ ] cut mm-hmm bowl cut
i like that that is a very country cut
too you can tell that his mother did
that cut go in on that's emmett on the
second row in the middle zoom in on him
it's clean
yeah it's clean and dirty at the same
time you can tell somebody did that at
his house with scissors i've had that
cut yeah yeah that's a good cut that
bangs the bangs you can tell i'm gonna
go go back out
i'm gonna go with my boy uh
uh
i'm gonna roll with
i kind of like
little jack
oh that's cute yeah he's cute dude why
do you pick the phone with the with the
tongue bro i just wanted to make it up
to him by being nice i just feel like i
don't know what's going on all right
okay what happened brother so is the
champion this year
champion was
emmett
damn dude johnson
emmitt that's his daddy right there
uh nope that's just a guy
okay so some random guy bro this guy's
up to no good let's
let's see that guy's video real quick
yeah
yeah
little man
mullet boy emmy bailey wins the
competition 2500 check
hopefully he gets a lot of endorsements
that little [ __ ]
his hair give me one of them swirls with
that mullet whoa yeah buddy tearing it
up in the usa
oh this guy's gonna jerk off in his own
gas tank i bet
that's that kind of pervert son i've
been around that dude
they used to tell your truck will run
better if you come in
um
all right i got one more news story what
was that last thing that came up and
then we'll get bobby on his way man
uh we got a couple things we had the uh
what was the uh one more thing okay we
do one more thing we have the island and
the strippers
the story i like the island
yeah so uh let me pull this up here did
you read about this no i don't know
anything about islands bro miami is
experimenting with a plan to move all
their homeless people onto an island
dude that's a great idea man i guess
it's virginia island which is like off
the key somewhere um it hasn't started
yet but they're they're putting it in
motion they're going to put them all
there i guess
[Laughter]
[Music]
first of all miami has become it is so
there's so much wealth down there that
this is the kind of thing you're gonna
start seeing man yeah yeah and then
people tourists are gonna they're gonna
be tourist boats going out there to see
them i would i would go to that [ __ ]
island yeah like i [ __ ] miami i don't
feel good about all the glitz gucci all
that [ __ ] man yeah let's go to the
[ __ ] homeless island yeah right and
get malaria or whatever you know what
did they get there's probably diseases
there oh yellow fever everything they
have yeah yeah but then there's going to
be probably like a gift shop or
something on the island you're going to
be able to like get like those like a
picture taken with a homeless guy right
or like like a ewok statue made out of
meth scabs
like they could make art you know what i
mean like folk folksy art yeah
like you know a tooth necklace
right yeah yeah yeah yeah dude that'd be
cool that gift shop dude a f if we got
to run a gift shop on a homeless island
yeah but dude you're going to have you
know those crack if there's not dry if
they don't also ship drugs out there
they are going to swim back
oh dude you would have to you're right
what would you need to do to keep them
happy i think you'd have to put up
barricades and hide drugs in the middle
of the island
but would you helico i would drop them
in yeah right wouldn't you do that i
think you'd have to yeah just helicopter
what like you know weed for sure yeah
yeah i mean alcohol for sure opiums but
how much is this going to
sounds expensive and especially they're
gonna stay alive for so long out there
in the summer which they should they
don't want them to stay alive yeah but
yeah if you don't have proper programs
stuff like that they're just out there
on the island they're gonna be [ __ ]
killing each other dude it's gonna be
like zelda breath of the wild
yeah or that movie um
um escape from new york uh you ever see
that movie
what you've never seen escape from new
york i haven't seen that and i just
couldn't watch the boys i tried i didn't
like it yeah but escaping oh god you you
have to watch it okay can i tell you the
premise real quick it's much like yes
it's basically in the future right and
kurt russell plays snake eyes
okay and basically in the future new
york city
is now
one large prison so they just built a
wall around new york city and all
everyone that's a convict and gang
member they just live there
and that's it they just you know so like
when you're there you have to survive oh
wow right but i think it's going to be a
lot like that where you
you build a gigantic wall around the
island you have to ship you know [ __ ]
food or whatever and it's just like
anything goes
anything goes man
you think it's going to be scary for
those people that live there
i mean if there's no clinics or [ __ ]
police or you know i mean if they just
let them run wild
they're going to open 50 to 100 tiny
homes uh and then they're going to have
services there they say but they don't
go into a lot of specifics but there are
going to be like 50 to 100 tiny homes
they were experimenting with this in
venice too if you're familiar tiny homes
yeah it's a tiny hole man like the
little bad williams over there yeah
they're supposed to be hide and go seek
or something yeah yeah
i would put something like a creation
juice place yeah
right did they get acai bowls like you
got to do something healthy like you
know like ginger shots
right i would have one right if they
want to get healthy
right ginger shots yeah yeah yeah you
know what i mean some homelessness yeah
wheat grass we grasp
i think you've got to have crops for
them to work you need to have some sort
of farming system sustainable food yeah
um they're gonna have severe sunburn and
skin i don't know i but also i could see
them filming it and putting it on some
kind of closed circuit television and we
all pay for it it's an extra live feed
type of thing yeah yeah i'm saying
that's where we're headed it's getting
weird i mean we're literally reading an
article they're gonna put homeless
people on an island wow that's how
australia got started man
they put criminal people on an island
yeah that's what they did right and it's
great now so maybe it is for the best
wow you think they'll have children out
there and stuff oh dude yeah if you
don't there's you don't see them grow up
but they have them you know
yeah yeah
all right so we could have but maybe
this is a good idea and in california
what do we do catalina yeah or the
desert catalina is a [ __ ] dump let's
put them out there yeah they make it
cool with that carousel or whatever but
yeah yeah
it doesn't feel like you're even on an
island i know it's so weak this is like
[ __ ] irvine but like surrounded by
water
right like there's no like tropical
trees it's just like irvine a hill it's
terrible yeah it's like a [ __ ] it's like
it's a [ __ ] hole it's it's a [ __ ] one
shitty section of a zoo there's bison
there there's no real native americans
they charge you to get out there i hate
there's couples breaking up on the way
there that when that are going for their
honeymoon it's [ __ ] unbelievable
[ __ ] catalina that's what's going on
yeah
well
so i'll see you tomorrow morning oh yeah
huh yeah [ __ ] we gotta be there early
7 45 man
really
and that's
every day monday to friday
no i'm i'm only there three days this
week
yeah what happens you know you're not i
my guy leaves
my guy doesn't leave i have to be every
day
but you get to really do you shine
yesterday on that baseball field i
didn't do nothing bro i had no line but
all the shots were all the shots were
hilarious no no no oh my god anyway with
this one
oh yeah maybe
dude there were so many good ones
but thank you theo i love you
um and everyone forced fox to pressure
the show and then um i'm proud of you
man i love you i love you too we're
gonna go to [ __ ] austin in january
all right let's try it out bro how great
what if we opened up joe's club maybe he
would let us be the opener for the first
week yeah i'll be great i'll see if he
will all right bye all right love you
bobby now i'm just floating on the
breeze and i feel i'm falling like these
leaves i must be
cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i can feel it
[Music]